[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert König
mit Handball und Wintersport ja guten
Abend es war ein pralles demowochenende
in
Deutschland Proteste gegen
Rechtsextremismus hunderttausende sind
auf den Straßen auch wieder in kleinen
Städten und AFD Hochburgen
familienforderung für vielverdiener die
FDP will den steuerlichen
Kinderfreibetrag anheben die
Koalitionspartner sagen dann müsse auch
das Kindergeld steigen und spektakulärer
Sieg im Slalom der Münchner Linus
Strasser gewinnt das Weltcuprennen in
kitsbül als erster deutscher seit 10
Jahren diese Menschen machen uns allen
Mut so würdigte Bundespräsident
Steinmeier die Demonstrierenden heute
sie verteidigen unsere Republik und
unser Grundgesetz gegen seine Feinde
100.000 Menschen waren es heute nach
Polizeiangaben in München wohl ebenso
viele in Berlin 70.000 in Köln und auch
in AFD Hochburgen im Osten gingen viele
gegen Rechtsextremismus auf die Straße
Volker dutcheck
berichtet demonstrieren hat auch immer
was mit zivilkourage zu tun in kotbus
wissen das viele denn kotbus hat seit
Jahren eine rechtsradikale Szene die
bundesweit Schlag seinen macht dennoch
am Ende sind rund 3500 Menschen auf der
Straße einig im Widerstand gegen
Ausländerfeindlichkeit mittenendrin
Ministerpräsident Dietmar wke viele hier
wollen sich nicht wegducken eine Bund
gemischte Truppe von Vertretern aus
Parteien Kirchen Sozialverbänden und
natürlich auch Privatleuten ich glaube
das es einfach auch mut bedeutet sich
hier hinzustellen und sich
dagegenzustellen und deshalb auch hier
zu zeigen dass wir auch in
Ostdeutschland hier in kotbus ja
dagegenstehen wir haben immer zusammen
gelebt wir werden auch immer noch
zusammen leben und wir lassen niemandem
dieses Zusammenleben verhändern ich bin
hier weil ich als Bürgerin dafür stehe
dass endlich mal klar wird dass die AFD
eine Minderheit ist und nicht die
Mehrheit ist auch in Dresden sind viel
mehr Menschen unterwegs als erwartet am
Nachmittag geschätzt 25 000 viele
dresner Werren sich gegen den
negativstempel den die pegida Bewegung
vor fast 10 Jahren hinterlassen hat ein
breit Bündnis tritt gegen
Einschüchterungsversuche von rechts
an ich glaube es aber doch eigentlich
eher der Anhaltspunkt dass viele Leute
das Gefühl haben hier entgleitet ein was
und man möchte auch mal wieder zeigen
dass die AFD nicht die Mitte der
Gesellschaft darstellt also das ist
jetzt so auf die Höhe getrieben was die
AFD von sich gibt dass ich wirklich
fassungslos bin und ich finde das ganz
wichtig dass jetzt wir Menschen wir
Bürger einfach ein Zeichen setzen die
solidarisierungswelle gegen
Rechtsextremismus geht durchs Land
München Köln und Berlin sind es schon
zusammen 300.000 Demonstranten zahlen
die vielen zeigen dass sie mit ihrem
Protest nicht allein
sind die meisten Familien mit Kindern
bekommen vom Staat 250 € Kindergeld pro
Monat wer sehr gut verdient nutzt
dagegen den Kinderfreibetrag den will
Finanzminister Lindner erhöhen
Koalitionspartner SPD und Grüne fordern
dann müsse aber auch das Kindergeld
steigen damit nicht nur Familien mit
hohen Einkommen profitieren klaus
brutbeck hat Details Lindners Plan nur
den Kinderfreibetrag zu erhöhen das
Kindergeld aber nicht sei abgesprochen
heißt es bei der FDP mit dem Kanzler
selbst den neuen Ärger in der Ampel
wollen die Liberalen nicht
verstehen das Kindergeld ist ja bereits
schon zum 1 des vergangenen Jahres
erhöht worden und das war die
Vereinbarung innerhalb der Koalition
dass in einem ersten Schritt das
Kindergeld erhöht wird aber aber auch im
nächsten Schritt einen höheren
Kinderfreibetrag eingesetzt wird damit
auch diejenigen entlastet werden die vor
allem das ganze finanzieren also die
eine Entlastung für die
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler nur
Eltern die mehr als etwa 40.000 € allein
oder 80.000 zu zweit verdienen würden
von dem höheren Freibetrag profitieren
je besser das Einkommen desto mehr wer
drunter liegt ginge leer aus spdchef
klingball nennt das ungerecht Ärger auch
beim grünen Koalition
Partner jetzt müssen Kindergeld und
Kinderfreibetrag in gleichem Maße weiter
angehoben werden weil es nicht sein kann
dass die Kinder von
Vorstandsvorsitzenden von Managern jetzt
23 € mehr im Monat kriegen sollen
während die Kinder von Polizistinnen und
von Polizisten von lagerarbeitern von
Verkäuferinnen und Verkäufern leer
ausgehen wir wollen dass wir alle Kinder
gleichermaßen berücksichtigen des wegen
müssen Kinderfreibetrag und Kindergeld
in gleichem Maße steigen
Familienministerin und finanz Minister
sein über die Pläne in Gesprächen heißt
es freundlich dürften die kaum
sein zum Krieg in der Ukraine beim
Beschuss der von Russland besetzten
Stadt donetk starben mindestens 25
Menschen so örtliche Behörden 20 weitere
Menschen wurden demnach verletzt der
Angriff habe am Morgen stattgefunden an
einem Markt gegolten auf dem viele
gerade einkauften Russland macht die
Ukraine für den Beschuss verantwortlich
Kiev äußerte sich bisher nicht
un Generalsekretär guteresch hat erneut
Israel scharf kritisiert die
Militäreinsätze hätten massenhafte
Zerstörung verbreitet und Zivilisten in
einem Ausmaß getötet wie er es als
Generalsekretär noch nicht erlebt habe
in Israel selbst demonstrierten tausende
gegen die Regierung Netanyahu sie solle
sofort alles für die Freilassung der von
der Terrororganisation Hamas
verschleppten Geiseln tun Michael
bewerunge aufsehenerregende Aufnahmen
von tunnelgefängnissen im Süden von Gaza
in denen israelische Geisel nach Angaben
der Armee gefangen gehalten wurden auch
Zeichnungen eines inzwischen
freigelassenen fünfjährigen Mädchens
seinen gefunden worden wegen der 16 noch
immer verschleppten steigt der Druck auf
die Regierung Netanyahu der Protest
richtet sich immer mehr gegen deren
Kriegskurs
insgesamt die Macht etwas zu verändern
und in Ordnung zu bringen liegt in
unseren Händen Regierung muss nach Hause
gehen
jetzt das kriegskabinett selbst scheint
zerstritten ein Teil kritisiert allein
militärischer Druck werde die Geisel
nicht befreien umstritten auch die
Nachkriegsordnung für Gaza und das
Westjordanland Netanyahu Lindt eine
Zweistaatenlösung kategorisch ab ich
stelle eines klar jede Regelung in
absehbarer Zukunft ein vernehmlich oder
nicht muss die Sicherheitskontrolle
Israels über das gesamte Territorium
westlich des Jordans beinhalten das ist
unvereinbar mit dem Prinzip der
Souveränität ganz anders klang der
US-Präsident nach einem Telefonat mit
Israels premier netano so beiden habe im
Gespräch mit ihm eine zwei staatenlösung
nicht
ausgeschlossen doch der dementiert
prompt mit ihm werde es keinen
palästinensischen Staat
geben und so geht dieser Krieg mit hin
und her weiter ohne Finales Ziel und
ohne absehbares
Ende
wer in der Nacht in Ostdeutschland in
den Himmel geschaut hat der konnte mit
etwas Glück ein seltenes Naturschauspiel
sehen nah Berlin ist ein kleiner
Asteroid verglüht zu sehen war der
Feuerball bis nach Leipzig der Asteroid
hatte einen Durchmesser von etwa ein
Meter und war erst kurz vor dem Eintritt
in die Erdatmosphäre entdeckt worden
Bruchstücke des Himmelskörpers werden im
hafelland
vermutet und jetzt Sport für linusstasse
ist in kützbül ein Traum in Erfüllung g
allerdings er hat den Klassiker im
alpinen Slalomsport gewonnen einmal am
ganzlerhang triumphieren was zuvor Vater
und Sohn neuruter sowie Armin bitner
gelungen war das hat jetzt als Vierter
deutscher auch Linus Strasser geschafft
die goldene Gams zu
erbeuten es ist eine passende Geste für
den Sieg im mecker des alpinen Skisports
Linus Strasser liegt nach dem ersten
Lauf in Lauerstellung auf Platz 4 mit
einem famosen zweiten Durchgang in Lauf
Bestzeit schiebt der 31 Jahre alte
Münchner noch ganz nach vorn als Vierter
deutscher trägt sich Strasser nun in die
hochkaretige Siegerliste
ein aber ich habe dann schon gemerkt im
Ziel dass es gut war das sehr gut war
der Grill Jakobs Jakobson hat noch ein
bisschen Spann gemacht den Schweden
Jakobsen und den Schweizer Jule kann
Strasser knapp hinter sich lassen bei
diesem bisher größten Erfolg seiner
Laufbahn der Österreicher Stefan Kraft
hat beim Skisprung Weltcup in sakopane
schon den siebten saisonseg gefeiert
auch Andreas Wellinger kann sich freuen
ein Flug auf
137 m bringt die noch von Rang 6 auf
Rang
2 es ist der Knalleffekt des 18
Bundesliga Spieltags Mitchell weiser
sorgt mit seinem Treffer für den 1:0
Auswärtssieg von werder-bremen beim
Rekordmeister bayern- München der hat
sieben Punkte Rückstand auf
Tabellenführer
Leverkusen mit einem blauen Auge davon
gekommen im schlussspur Schaffen
deutschlandsh Handballer bei der in Köln
noch ein 22 Z22 gegen das
Überraschungsteam Österreich
ausgelassene Freude gestern bei den
Österreichern Enttäuschung dagegen beim
Gastgeber und er dafür verantwortlich
Austria Keeper Konstantin möstel mit
fast 50% gehaltenen bellen gegenüber
Andreas Wolf hatte alle Hände voll zu
tun sein Team im Spiel zu halten ich bin
nicht zufrieden mit der Angriffsleistung
ich denke dass ist niemand heute ein
großes Lob muss ich meine Abwehr
aussprechen insgesamt auch dem Charakter
der Mannschaft dass obwohl wir kurz
Schluss mit vier Toren hinten war nicht
aufgesteckt haben dank Christoph Steiner
reicht am Ende wenigstens zu einem Punkt
jetzt müssen zwei Siege her heute haben
sie es erstmal mit kleineren Bällen
probiert um am Ende wieder großes zu
erreichen und zwar gegen Ungarn morgen
20:15 Uhr live für ZDF da sind wir dabei
klar ja das zauberhafte Winterwetter ist
erstmal vorbei morgen gibt's viele
Wolken und zeitweise Regen dabei vor
allem im Südosten vorübergehend Glatteis
möglich stürmischer Südwestwind an der
Nord und auf den Bergen orkanböhnen 4
bis
11° auch in den nächsten Tagen mild
wechselhaft stürmisch und starkes
Tauwetter morgen übernimmt hier Jana
pareiges wir sagen danke und tschüss und
empfehlen jetzt Diana Zimmermann und
Berlin direkt